[Music]
i think it's going to surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
it's going to be different from any
superhero movie ever made
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
than james gunn i was excited with an
opportunity to be able to do
the suicide squad in the way it could be
done from my point of view
this one is completely unique this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters and comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy of characters within each of our
characters there's a certain beauty
within most of them some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
be like a douchey captain america the
guy who believes in peace
at any cost no matter how many people he
needs to
kill along the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone is exploding genitals heads
arms legs
it's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life
this is by far the biggest movie i've
ever made
i don't think that you know what to
expect
don't get too attached this has been
truly
the greatest most exciting
journey of my life making this film
cut that was great
[Music]
you